If your website isn't mobile-friendly, prepare to see your Google Search rankings plummet.
It's being called "Mobilegeddon."
Google is tweaking its search results to give preference to sites...
...optimized for mobile devices.
Okay, so Mobilegeddon is a little dramatic,...
...but the changes will certainly put some businesses at a disadvantage,...
...specifically small and medium-size businesses that don't have the same tech resources...
...that huge companies have.
So now, the local mom-and-pop diner is...
...even more likely to rank behind major chains in search results.
And it's not just the little guys taking a hit here.
Sites for the European Union, BBC and even Wikipedia,...
...all rank low on Google's Mobile-Friendly Test.
The test accounts for things like text size, amount of space between links...
...and how the content displays on small screens.
Google says it's simply adapting to the times.
A 2014 study found that in the US, mobile devices account for 60%...
...of time spent on digital media.
But the changes are certainly bad news for sites not optimized for mobile.
Research by online advertising analyst Jatika...
...shows that the first result in the Google search...
...gets almost a third of the traffic share and if a site doesn't rank in the top 10,...
...then it can pretty much kiss any help for traffic from the search engine goodbye.